genau so fährt mit segway beute ist
eigentlich eigentlich zieht way halte
mein name ist sogar herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einer neuen episode von
gott simulator da geht es darum dass wir
eine kleine dumme ziegel sind die jetzt
heftig gerade auf einer woche habe ich
schon mal einen part gott simulator aus
dieser neuen map namens waste of space
hochgeladen
ich glaube ich ist abgestürzt ja das war
klasse auf jeden fall
und in der letzten episode habe ich
gesagt falls ihr 40.000 likes klappen
sollte wird eine neue episode kommen ihr
habt 40.000 leicht gesagt freunde von
daher freunde wenn ich in einer woche
wieder einen neuen park golfsimulator
hochladen soll dann lasst 50.000 like da
ja also wenn euch das gefällt da schon
mal leicht da und jetzt spielen wir auch
wirklich
wir befinden uns ja immer noch hier
draußen nachdem wir dort in diesem kraut
kicker gebäude drin waren ich würde
allerdings sagen dass wir dann noch mal
kurz eben rein gehen denn es ist so ich
erstmal meine maske hier ab es ist
nämlich möglich beziehungsweise jetzt
wurde mir die kommentare geschrieben
dass ich jetzt neues geld hier bekomme
also das ist nicht so mein gott wir
haben es geschafft wir haben die
gründung eines raumflug museums
hingekriegt freunde
das sieht dann müssen wir gleich auf
jeden fall mal hin was viele leute in
den kommentaren meinten war ganz einfach
heyo k du kannst einfach wieder in
diesen bereich gehen und wieder ein paar
leute hier umschubsen da kriegst du auf
jeden fall wieder geld weil ich habe mir
wirklich schon gedanken gemacht wo ich
denn das ganze geld überhaupt herkriegen
soll für die ganzen ziele die ich
irgendwie erreichen muss also ich musste
ja nach und nach alles irgendwie
aufbauen freischalten was ist dieses
spiel ist zu bescheuert
allein die tatsache dass ich leute
wegschicken muss damit ich deren geld
bekommen ist ja echt schon wahnsinn
auf jeden fall ist der des
dieser map dass ich im weltraum bin und
das ist nicht das ziel das ist einfach
die begebenheit gerade gut man empfehle
ich muss irgendwie neue sachen
freischalten hier habe ich zum beispiel
die kolonie schon in der letzten folge
freigeschaltet falls ihr die letzte
folge wie soll ich gesehen habe hatte
ich immer hier oben ich werde nie
vergessen haben die folge zu verlinken
also sucht einfach kompletter luca bei
youtube die landeplattform ihren wir
noch nicht freigeschaltet
allerdings haben wir hier bleibt geld
drin ja genau jetzt auch noch geld
dankeschön fürs geld kolonie hier haben
wir auf jeden fall schon freigeschaltet
das heißt da sind wir wieder wo wir
letztes mal oh mein gott hier sind wir
sind segways ein paar sekunden später
bei gott ich ja genau so fährt eine
ziege zeigt wo er heute ist eigentlich
eigentlich sie quaid wir führen jetzt
einfach mal mit diesem hofer bei grund
fahren ja das hat das hat super
funktioniert genau so fährt man auch
hofer bike also ich weiß nicht warum ich
hier mit rum fahren sollte weil leuchtet
es ist einfach echt schwer zu fahren und
auch langsam das noch geld dankeschön
letztes mal haben wir den beiden hier
das date versaut das heißt das machen
wir jetzt wieder tschüssi die
hoffnungslose romantiker habe ich
letztens bekommen auf jeden fall werden
wir in dieser folge nun mal schauen was
wir denn was ist denn das kann ich mit
irgendwas machen
ich will mir auf jeden fall mal unser
neues raumflug museum ankucken ich weiß
noch nicht genau wo das ist das ding ist
allerdings dass wir einfach mal y
drücken können wir sehen schon gründung
eines raumflug museums das haben wir
abgeschlossen
das stretch ziel aber das hier kann man
ziemlich 1 4 viel heftigere hofer bei
kaufen das kostet halt 9000 dollar dabei
sorry leg mich einfach mal dazu dann
sollte es endlich klagen ja ich weiß
ehrlich gesagt allerdings noch gar nicht
genau wo dieses raumflug museum ist da
es im kopf wie spot wir haben hier aries
kooperation
wir haben hier verschiedene gebäude
diesem app ist riesig also kein scheiß
auf finde und gewinne drei ärzte der mit
der letzten folge auch schon gegen
solche komischen steiger gefunden habe
ich hab mir war kommentare durchgelesen
hat alle oder sind ärzte die brauchst
für später geld brauche ich auf jeden
fall auch oh mein gott
hofer bike wir haben eine haube
angeblich kann ich geh drücken da wir
jetzt herbei ach du ach du scheiße ist
ja einfach eine ziege die durch den
weltraum fährt was ist das jetzt ist ein
radar schüssel oder irgendwie so können
wir das planet erde diese komplette map
ist einfach so unfassbar riesige müssen
wir belegen bisher waren wir nur in
diesen dingen darin diesem kleinen grün
und hier wartet noch das alles auf uns
also ich weiß gar nicht genau wo wir
anfangen sollten
am liebsten würde ich mir einfach mal
das raumflug museum anschauen aber ich
finde es nicht
ich will doch keine ahnung wie es ist
ich fühle mich jetzt einfach mal hier
rein allen freunde was haben wir denn
hier dom erforschtes kölner dom also
dass er echt ne riesige stiegen hier
leute okay was haben wir hier sind leute
die baumarten rakete komme ich mir
dieses rohrbeck weg kommt jetzt wieder
zurück wenn ich ach du scheiße ist das
geil alter die runden eines breit
flasche wir haben cola flaschen cetera
pp wasser baut dieses
ok und roboter und hallo richtig
mitnehmen
im kern heißt der also ich weiß ehrlich
gesagt nicht ganz genau was das sie
jetzt ist ja einfach mal im weltraum mit
einem regenschirm und und hot dogs
verkaufen oder so wenn ich einen haben
vielleicht auch nein danke hey ich
wollten hotdog und nicht dicht ein
fahrstuhl noch ein roboter hallo sorry
ich weiß nicht was hier abgeht hier sind
wieder irgendwelche menschen die mir
geld geben was ist das hier wie love is
103 also mal schauen was hier irgendwie
gemacht wird was sind das kühlste
preisgekrönter kürbis zu geld
danke schön ist halt echt völlig
bescheuert die machen ihr irgendwelche
experimente und ich wünsche euch auf
jeden fall noch ein ganz ganz gutes
gelingen da drin freunde
was geht hier von oh mein gott eine
menge geld hier vorne haben wir den raum
07 anscheinend was hier gemacht
also
und
ich frage mich gar nichts mehr hier in
dem einen raum werden irgendwelche
kürbisse gezüchtet hier in dem raum ist
irgendwie sonne fliegen kann ich dir an
decken
dann wird meine zunge wenigstens mal
richtig gedehnt hier der typ hier ist
nur am klatschen hin wie und diese
andere frau guckt dass sie tatsächlich
relativ ungesund aus aber gut ich meine
ich das nicht einfach mal liegen in
einem der hier klatsch natürlich wieder
hier liegt auch noch eine am boden
hiervon aber noch ein bisschen geld für
mich dass ich natürlich mein eigenes
raumschiff motto mein gott ich habe mir
ich habe mein eigenes raumschiff
freigeschaltet also ja alle miteinander
an der frauen der wand ich wünsche euch
noch ganz ganz viel spaß hier vorne hat
sich holen gesehen habe hier hinter ist
auch noch ein bisschen erz ich weiß
immer noch nicht was wir mit dem mit dem
er zu machen sollen aber online ok
schönes leben dir dann noch davor
notieren wir wieder unseren komischen
hot dog verkäufer du kannst eigentlich
mal weggehen ganz nach vorne hot dogs
verkaufen ich weiß immer noch nicht was
hier abgeht freunde wir sind in der
folge der rollator bei 20 minuten nein
die müssen ja video schon langsam
beenden
aber die sache ist wir haben bisher es
wirklich nur diesen dom erforscht und
ich weiß nicht mal was hier gemacht wird
was ist denn hier los ist dass leute ich
habe überhaupt keine ahnung was ihr alle
von mir wollen in dem raum hier war ich
glaub ich auch noch nicht was ist denn
das ist einfach nur ein parkplatz an
alle unter euch die dieses codes
simulator ways of space schon mal
gespielt haben
wisst ihr was ich hier machen soll ich
habe gerade einen raumschiff träger
freigeschaltet ach du scheiße leute ich
glaube wir können dann mit unserem
eigenen raumschiff aus diesem kompletten
ding raus fliegen in unseren raumschiff
träger und sind dann mehr im weltall als
jetzt als das irgendwie sinn gemacht hat
also wir haben wirklich bisher eine
menge menge geld gesammelt streetfood
sieht nach ehrlich gesagt nicht zum
leckeren street food aus hamm ist ja
unglaublich viel geld gesammelt wir
haben dieses ding wo ich immer noch
nicht weiß was es uns bringt wir haben
überall so ziegen rumstehen wir haben
hier test chambers wir haben da hinten
diesen kraut kicker gegen wo wir auch
noch nicht alles frei geschaltet haben
da hatten wir auch noch diese
landeplattform oder sowie die wir noch
freischalten mussten glaube ich hier
sind wirklich noch nicht ansatzweise
überall gewesen in diesem etwas ist dass
hier was waren das hier die haben hier
vorne sonne die holzbrücke die irgendwie
weitergeht was ist denn das kann ich
hier mit sich herum fahren wir haben
hier wieder so ein paar geld kisten
rumliegen ich glaube auch mittlerweile
dass das hier so eine explosion piste
ist oder ja das war eine explosions
christel leute ich komme wirklich nicht
drauf klar wie sich diese map ist wie
viele möglichkeiten es gibt was wir
alles machen können es gibt nicht zum
ersten mal bei gott simulator die
möglichkeit sage ich mal so ein bisschen
so eine story aufzubauen
ich kann sachen frei schalten und so
weiter und so fort hallo ich bin neben
den dann mal mit nem also ich weiß
wirklich nicht im wahrsten sinne des
wortes was hier abgeht was ihr vor sich
also warum hast du ein baseballschläger
hier vorn haben wir noch einen coffee
stop
hallo so komme ich da nicht rein
also hier sehen die außerdem fette ziege
drin ich habe keine ahnung was mit der
ich hab mit teleporter freigeschaltet
wenn man mit dem teleporter dann
irgendwie ja sich teleportieren könnte
ich glaube tatsächlich dass der winter
dem teleporter ist ich bin auf jeden
fall gespannt was sie noch alles kommen
wird in diesem ding sms liegt überall
gelten also wir schalten wirklich
pausenlos irgendwas frei ich bin aber
ganz ehrlich wir haben in dieser folge
keine zeit mehr
jetzt alles zu testen von wegen
raumschiff und traumschiff träger und
alles mögliche und da habe ich das
heutige video auch an dieser stelle
beenden meine damen und herren wenn es
euch gefallen hat und ihr in der
nächsten woche noch einen neuen park
golf simulator haben wollt wo wir dann
beispielsweise unser raumschiff mal
testen oder auch zu dem raumflug museum
endlich mal gehen oder da oben ist zum
beispiel eine landeplatz und damit frei
geschaltet als 50.000 leichter freund
ich habs jetzt beginnen schon gesagt
haben das zeigt mir einfach wie viel
bock darauf haben dass ich gott
simulator wieder öfter hochladen sage
ich mal schreibt mir tipps und
kommentare falls der waste of space
schon gespielt haben falls ihr wisst
luca das musst du machen das ist geil
dass wir interessantes video und sonst
will ich auch noch ein wunderschönen tag
[Musik]